the u.s senate has approved 40 billion
dollars in new aid to ukraine and this
comes as a startling body cam footage
emerges from the early days of russia's
brutal campaign against the city of
mariupol which appears to now be in its
final hours you're looking now at video
taken by a medic who has since been
captured by russian forces
mts taeyab is in ukraine with the medic
story and we need to warn you once again
that some of this video you've heard
this phrase before is very hard to watch
mts good morning to you
gail good morning to you well as we know
hundreds of ukrainian forces have been
surrendering to russia as prisoners of
war and all of that has really put focus
on the attention rather of yulia
payevska who has essentially been in
russian custody since march
it's a window into russia's brutal war
on ukraine yulia pyevska a ukrainian
medic recorded the first weeks of
moscow's ruthless assault on the port
city of mariupol on a body camera
following a russian shelling this
brother and sister whose parents were
killed were treated by her team
the little girl lived but the boy's body
couldn't survive the trauma
a loss too painful for her to bear
[Music]
known as tyra her online gaming name the
53-year-old mother found her calling as
a medic following russia's 2014 invasion
of crimea
through her body camera she documented
this war
including her insistence captured
russian prisoners be treated humanely
tyra had the footage smuggled out of
medieval on a tiny memory card and
slipped it to the associated press
the following day on march 16 she and
her driver were captured by russian
forces
she was not seen again until this
shocking appearance on russian tv
where russian media accused her of being
a neo-nazi
comparing her haircut to adolf hitler's
and claimed she was working for
ukraine's ultra-nationalist azov
battalion
part of russia's narrative that it's
attempting to de-nazify ukraine but
according to the ap it's found no such
evidence
sergey chernovitz worked closely with
tyra and says she had no ties to azov
she was a real medic she says she was
apolitical and helped everyone who
needed it
now according to the ukrainian
government she's really dedicated her
lives to saving the lives of others and
not war and they're calling on russia
and to release her and indeed other
ukrainians in their custody nate
that was eye-opening thank you so much
mts tab in ukraine we appreciate you